well let's talk to former member of the
sex pistols glenn matlock who you saw
in that little clip there good to see
you this morning look how
important is it to to keep alive all
these
these little spots that have been the
heart of music over the decades
well it's very important they're the
proving ground where bands who
kind of starting out um maybe kind of
continuing their careers you know
the musical career is like a roller
coaster it's very up and down
um but that's where all the big bands
come through from
i was talking to jeff horton at 100 club
a while back
and he was saying that all the bands
that have played at glastonbury over
maybe over the last 10 years
seventy percent of them have started out
at the under club
you know and other clubs like that all
around the country if you lose them
you kind of lose everything really yeah
yeah
in this sort of day of of of x factor
and all that sort of thing where people
get instant stardom you do forget don't
you
a little bit that that these bands
they're sort of the quality bands and
really have to prove their worth in
these
by touring around the small venues
well yeah so you build up a following
but
you mentioned x factor i wouldn't
particularly call that music to be
honest
you know bands of any kind of
consequence was something i have to say
do that whole proving ground thing and
that's how they learn their trade that's
how they sort of
separate the wheat from the chaff of
what songs work with the audience and
which ones don't
then you know and that's basically
you've got to keep that going otherwise
you've got nothing you know and that
happens
not only in this country but all around
the world there's a whole
touring scene through europe or there
was i mean how brexit's gonna affect
that i really don't know
i think it's a terrible travesty but um
you know we need the support and there
hasn't been much support i i was booking
some shows
for july hopefully on sort of winging a
prayer
and now i've just found out that because
of the indian variant up in the midlands
they want to
reschedule nobody knows what's going on
you know and you can't
base a career and and
you're living in your livelihood and
engage all the other people who are
playing with you
on the basis of not what not knowing
what's going on
yeah there is i mean yeah there is a a
lot of confusion at the minute but when
we get things sorted and straightened
out a little bit which hopefully will
will happen before too long you really
want i mean through this series it's
all about encouraging people to to
really get back to their local venues
and there is something about
um the intimacy isn't there and and and
seeing a band when they're a little bit
more raw and being at the beginning of
their journey which is brilliant for a
for a music fan isn't it
there is that's why it's all about i
think if you know if you're a songwriter
which i consider myself
as an and you're kind of engaging with
people which
with a song that you might have written
40 minutes ago or 40 years ago
and when people kind of pick up on what
you're trying to say
and identify with it it's great if
you're doing a big arena
that's kind of cool because you're doing
well but in a club
when you can see the whites of people's
eyes you know and they appreciate and
dig where you're coming from and
identify but
it's a really big buzz and not only just
for the
for the artists but also for the fan too
you know
and you only get that in the close
proximity but how are you going to get a
close proximity with what's going on
i've been invited to chrissy hayne
invited me to some show she's doing soon
and well i really like to go i don't
know if it's a good idea at the moment
you know
you got that as war you know and there's
one thing being like being on the stage
and in the dressing room and
i did when the lockdown was lifted i
played with my band at um
the electric forum in camden for late
september
october it was and that was sort of a
socially distant show
and there wasn't that many people there
because it wasn't allowed to be there
but
i was fortunate and i was backstage and
i could have my own little dress
but look we've got to we've got to keep
our fingers crossed
but not have to engage with people yeah
well look got to gotta keep our fingers
crossed that things get better so
really good to talk to you glenn thank
you